agora uma coisa irmão só quem fala mal
do irmão da gente é a gente é igual você
tá nos Estados Unidos falar do Brasil
Rapaz o Brasil está se acabando cara é
violência não tem mais segurança a
educação tá tá ruim ninguém consegue
[__] nenhuma o Brasil tá um lixo cara
vira para tu fala é realmente o Brasil
tem um lixo ó como é que rapaz tu vai
cuidar do teu país seu [__] ai Brasil
está um lixo tu respeita o Brasil tu
começa a ser igual ao tamanho começa a
botar umas qualidades para ver se
levanta o Brasil um pouquinho mas pelo
menos tem Neymar vocês tem Neymar não
tem Neymar aí tomar no teu cu quando tu
tiver Neymar tu fala comigo seu [__]
aprende a chantagear os outros porque só
quem tem irmão sabe que chata já é filho
único não é preparado pra vida pra poder
fazer uma chantagem de uma pessoa desde
criança aprende ele vê tu chegando de
madrugada escondido de uma festa e fala
hum fostes para festas irmãos